- We are the paradoxical ape, bipedal,
naked, large brain. Long the master of
fire, tools, and language but still trying
to understand ourselves. Aware that death
is inevitable, yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly. We hand down knowledge,
we empathize and deceive, we shape the
future from our shared understanding
from the past. Carta brings together
experts from diverse disciplines to
exchange insights on who we are and
how we got here.
An exploration made possible by the
generosity of humans like you.
- Thanks very much and thanks all
of you for coming.
It's wonderful to be here and talk
to such an incredible audience.
I thought I'd start off by posing
a question I think
is particularly relevant to all of us
thinking about language evolution and that
is what's so special about language. In a
sense the goal of evolutionary linguistics
is to try and explain the origins of the
special properties of language. They're
are two that I want to focus on today, in
fact Roger started with one of them.
First off I want to highlight structure.
Language has a highly unusual and rich
systematic structure in the way it's put
together. So when I say the phrase
"two boots" you're able to relate to the
acoustic wave form that hits your ears to
this rather cute picture of my son's shoes
on this slide. Now how are you able to do
that? You're able to do that because of
the special structure that language has.
The signals that we produce are
constructed sequences of these meaningless
elements. We call them phonyms, these
different phonyms are put together in
different ways, reorganized in different
ways to make up the sounds of our language
in sequences. But further more these
meaningless elements are themselves put
together to make more morphemes, the
meaning carrying elements of language,
These are put together to construct
meaningful holes. So you understand what
two boots means because you understand the
ways in which language recombines
elements. It's because of this
recombination, because we can endlessly
recombine elements at these
two different levels that
we are able to talk about anything.
So we're able to constantly reproduce
completely new utterances
with a happier expectation that
everyone can understand us.
This is an incredible feat and
remarkably it seems to
be unique to our species. So that was one
of the special features of language
structure. Next up, the other one I want
to talk about is learning. We are able to
use language because we have learned both
how to produce the signals in our language
and we've also learned perhaps
even more remarkably
what the signals in our language mean.
We're able to use language meaningfully
because we've observed language being used
around us as we grow up. Again this
combination of learning the signals and
learning the meanings seems to be unique
in nature. What I'm particularly
interested in is the fact that this is a
very particular kind of learning. When we
learn language we're learning from the
product of other people who have gone
through the same learning process. We
learn from the observation from the of the
output of other learners. This is
something that I call iterated learning
and it's a particular and relatively
unusual process in nature. What iterated
learning means is the language that
I speak and I learned by observing
language being produced by my parents and
the language that I produce is going on
to affect my son and daughter are
acquiring. What this means is we have
this process of cultural transmission of
language through this mapping from
external production of language and some
internal representation of language.
What this means is that languages evolve,
so this is a kind of cultural evolution.
So language itself is an evolutionary
system in its own right.
What I want to suggest today that these
two features, structure and iterated
learning are related to each other. In
fact what I want to claim is language
structure is the inevitable consequence of
the fact that language is a culturally
evolving system. So I want to pose and
answer this question affirmatively that
cultural evolution can explain why
language has the structure that it does.
How on earth can we go about answering
this question? This is one of the
challenges of doing evolutionary
linguistics is how on earth do you study
it scientifically? Well they're lots of
ways and you're going to hear about a lot
of them today. One of the ways that we
pioneered in my lab in Edinburgh was try
and recreate language evolution, the
cultural evolution of language in the
experiment lab. I'm going to show you how
we do that, I'm going to give you two
examples of two experiments that we've
done that will give you a flavor of the
way in which we can study cultural
evolution of language in the lab.
Generally how do we do this? We brought
together two kind of standard experimental
techniques from two different areas. One
was a paradigm from psycho-linguistics
called artificial  language learning where
we get participants into the lab
and teach them miniature
languages then test them.
Another technique from experimental
anthropology, I guess you would call it
called transmission chain paradigm and
this is the way people study the process
of cultural evolution in various different
domains. So we're just plucking those two
together. I'll talk you through in general
how it works and then I'll give you the
two specific examples. First off we bring
our participant into the lab and we ask
them to learn a miniature language.
So this is a very, very small miniature,
artificial language that we've created.
We might have them in the lab for an hour
maximum and then we test them. We get them
to produce utterances in this miniature
language. At this stage this is a standard
paradigm artificial language learning
paradigm. But the twist we put on it is we
use the output of that participant when we
test them to form the language that the
next participant in the lab is going to
learn from. Then we take the output of
that second participant and use that to
form the input and training data for the
third participant in the lab and so on. So
we create a chain of transmission of this
miniature language and watch how it
evolves as it passes from participant to
participant in our experiments. What we
typically do is we start with a language
in scare quotes that is random and
unstructured. It doesn't have the
structural properties that we're
interested in and then we want to see if
the structural properties emerge through
this process of transmission over these
artificial generations that we created in
the lab experiments. Okay, so that's the
general structure of this experimental
approach and I'm going to give you two
examples. So first example and this is
joint work with Hanna Cornish and Kenny
Smith, pictured there. This was our first
experiment, the first experiment we did in
our lab. As you can see 2008,
it's a relatively recent approach that
we've taken here. What we wanted to do was
look for this emergence of compositional
structure. Compositional structure is the
idea that you can put words together to
make meanings, so the meaning of a whole
expression is made up the meanings of part
of that expression. So we wanted to see if
we could get back to
a merge in these lab experiments.
Okay, so what participants did, so we have
this experimental chain of participants
and what the participants were asked to do
was learn a miniature language.
The language was made of of these weird
meanings which were colored shapes that
were moving in different ways and we have
three colors, three shapes, and three
different types of movement. So three
times three times three that makes 27
possible meanings in this language, when I
say miniature language I really mean
miniature. These pictures, these
meanings were paired with
strings of syllables and these were
just made up at random by the computer.
This is a completely unstructured,
arbitrary language, every single meaning
was given a different label and each
participant was trained on half of the
language but then was tested on all of the
meanings. So they were trained on half of
the meanings but then were asked to
produce strings of syllables for all of
the meanings when we tested them. There
There output then formed the
input for the next participant
in the lab and again we took a
random half of the
output of the first participant to
train the second one and
then test the second one and then take a
random half of their language to train the
third participant and so on down the
chain. So what happens? Well what we find
is the people are absolutely terrible at
this task. This graph shows error and it's
a rather forgiving measure of error. It
just said an error of one would mean that
you got not a single letter right in the
target word, an error of zero means you
get everything right. What you see here is
four different runs of the experiment and
each point on this graph is a
different participant.
The first participants in the lab had a
terrible time, in fact nobody got a single
word exactly right, essentially absolutely
awful. By the end however the
participants in the later
generations in these chains
some of them were getting
everything exactly right
including the meanings that they weren't
trained on. So they were successfully
guessing the correct label for meanings
that we didn't even train them on. So how
on earth is that happening? Well I'll show
you what the languages looked like as they
evolved. So here's an initial random
language, so for example in this table
"miniki" is the word for a blue square
that's moving horizontally.
Bear in mind if you're
trained on half of this language,
imagine if I blanked out half
of these words and
then I asked you to reconstruct the
missing words you'd have no hope, you
couldn't possibly get it right because
this is random. If you didn't know that
that word was "miniki" there's no way you
could guess it so that's
why they're doing so badly. This
is what that same language
looks like ten generations later.
So now you see how the
participants are doing this. So now if I
blanked off half of those words you'd be
able to successfully guess what those
missing words were. For example the word
"poi" now refers to all spiraling objects.
This language has evolved to become more
easy to learn but it's evolved in a
slightly kind of disappointing way from
our point of view. It's evolved by
jettisoning words in a particular way so
that these words refer to a sort of
sections of the set of meanings. So why is
this happening? In fact in some versions
of the experiment we go down
to a single word for all things.
So clearly we need something else in this
experiment, we need some kind of pressure
to be expressive as well as learnable for
the language. I can't go into the details
because I don't have time but what we
essentially did was we added in a filter
on the output of each participant. So we
threw out items that were ambiguous before
we passed it on to the next participants
and none of the participants could be
aware that we were doing this
manipulation. We ran the whole experiment
again with this hidden step and we got
completely different results. So here's
again the initial and another initial
language again completely random and now
ten generations later it looks quite
different. What I've done here is I've
added in hyphens to make it easier for you
to see but the participants don't get to
see these hyphens. What you see here is
that different parts of the signals
correspond to different parts of the
meanings. So for example this "n" prefix
means that black things, the "r" prefix
means red things, a "plo" suffix means
something that's bouncing and so on. This
is the compositionaility we were looking
for and it emerged out of this process of
cultural transmission. Structure seems
to emerge spontaneously from this process
of cultural evolution. Now there's a
couple of obvious worries that you might
have. Firstly perhaps the participants in
the experiment are kind of deliberately
thinking well this language is rubbish,
here's how we can fix it up, add some
structure. We don't think that's happening
because bear in mind these two different
runs of the experiment got very different
languages out, the participants couldn't
know which condition they were in. Another
possible objection is okay, but they
already speak a language, all of our
participants spoke English so it's not
surprising that they gradually
changed the system to be one that
looks more like a language.
That's a valid worry so we've recreated
all of this experiment in computer
simulation where we can know that our
computational participants don't have a
pre-existing language and we get the same
results. Okay, so that's my first example.
The second example we wanted to move away
from this starting point with these random
strings because that seems a bit weird.
Where do they come from?
Instead we start from potentially
a much more
natural starting point, one of
gestural pantomime. And we wanted to see
if we could evolve something that looked
like a structured sign
language, miniature structured sign
language out of an initial state that was
iconic pantomime. This is joint work with
Kenny Smith,
Katja Bramifer and Erica Cartmill.
Here's how the experiment works. In this
version of the experiment the meanings now
are videos of bouncing balls, so here's
one, that's the thing that had to be
conveyed and the signals are manual
gestures made to a video camera.
Something like this. The initial language
in this experiment was improvised one off
pantomimes that we got people into the lab
and said okay can you give the pantomime
that corresponds to this video.
Participants are trained
on 12 out of the 16 videos but
asked to produce gestures
for all 16 and then the same
process of this sort of
diffusion chain, transmission chain was
applied. So we'd see how the gestures
evolved over generations. I'll just show
you the full set of meanings, it's a
little alarming when you see it. So these
are all the different videos tiled
together and what you ca see here is
there's different paths in which the ball
moves along, so flat, sloping, in a "s"
shape or in a circle.
There are different manors so the ball
might be bouncing or rolling or spinning
or giving this nightmarish jittering
motion. So that's the set of meanings they
have to convey. This is what the initial
pantomimes look like for all the
participants we got in just to do one off
gesture for these. What you see here is
there's a huge range of different
strategies that people use to produce
these meanings, an enormous
diversity in strategies here.
What we were interested in, some of them
more successfully than others,
What we were interested in is how do
these strategies evolve down generations.
So here's our first
participant who saw 12 of these
and then produced a gesture
for each of them.
IT looks more systematic, that's just
because it's one person so they're
looking more similar. In fact, there's
still a lot of diversity
here if you look at the hand
shape used to convey the
ball and so on.
There's still a lot of diversity.
Much later in the same chain we have this
participant. Now it's looking much more
systematic. If you look at hand shape
for example it's now very similar across
all the different videos. There's
particular kinds of systematicity
we're interested in.
Here's an example from
another chain which I particularly like.
Have a look at what she's doing here
to convey the ball moving?
So she signals the ball and then
says the manner and then the path. So she
separated out two aspects of this meaning
compositionally into two different parts.
Indeed another interesting thing she does
here is she self corrects. She says "oh
no, I got it wrong" watch again, she'll do
it again. This indicates that at this
point in the evolution of the language
she's seeing that there's a right and
wrong answer, It's become grammatical.
Just to summarize these and I'll be done.
Over time the gestures in this language
become less pantomimic and more
conventional. We can actually measure
this, we can show that systematic
structure emerges over generations in this
experiment. Interestingly this separation
of manner and path mirrors what we can see
in real emerging sign languages. This is
work by Annie Singhouse and colleagues
looking at how Nicaraguan sign language,
an emerging sign language we get this
separation of manner and path emerging
over generations, over cohorts. So final
conclusions. I want to argue that language
is an evolutionary system in it's own
right and because of this languages adapt
and they adapt to pass more easily from
learner to learner. The linguistic
structure is the solution that cultural
evolution finds the problem of being
learnable. So it's an inevitable
consequence of the way language is
transmitted and we can and indeed we
should study this process in the
experiment lab, thank you very much.